Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from a
few more people today, we are now taking
calls via Discord. It typically works really,
really well. You can find the discord at David
Pakman Gqom slash discord. Let's go across the
pond. I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly.
Is it shanese in the United Kingdom?
Speaker 4: Hi, yes. Can you hear me,
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine,
are you calling in from Nottingham?
Speaker 4: I am, yes. What a
pleasure in the UK. What a pleasure.
Thanks. I'm a huge fan of the show. Thank
you. My question was I was just wondering,
why do you think that the left kind of branding
and messaging is generally so much less successful
than the right? I feel as though whenever you
know, the left come up with something like
defund the police or something like that, it just
kind of tends to cause like a lot of infighting.
It doesn't really tend to kind of let go as well,
whereas when the right come up with something, it
always tends to kind of work a little bit better.
Do you think it's just kind of I feel as if it's
almost like the bully in the playground let. The
right's voice is just louder. They kind of just
go along with points without really any kind of
evidence, but it tends to work better for them
than it does kind of for us on the left.
Speaker 1: Beautiful question. So I think
that there's two answers depending on the
circumstances. So sometimes the left just
comes up. Just brands a bad idea. OK, so like
defund the police wasn't a good idea. It was
a bad idea. And as I explained in my ten point
police reform plan, reallocation of resources?
Yes, reform replacing police with social workers
for some types of calls, yes. But in some places,
you might need to increase funding for police
in order to accomplish those things or to be at
the proper level of staffing in order to have
police be more proactive than reactive. OK,
so like defund the police was a bad idea because
as a slogan, because the idea itself is not a good
idea, that's one side. Right? But there's a whole
other set of examples which are sometimes the left
assumes that because we have the right idea that
the branding doesn't matter and we just have to
explain the idea and everybody will like it. And
the right who has the wrong idea is like, that
doesn't really matter. We just need a slogan and
they come up with a slogan and it works. I mean,
pro-life is a great example, and so is
tax relief. Pro-Life? Well, actually,
what you're doing is you're picking and choosing
certain medical situations that should be left
to patients and doctors and assigning a name
to it where if you're against it, it's like,
Wow, that you're anti anti-life. If you're
not pro-life, your entire life, by definition,
that's really good branding, even though the
policy makes no sense tax relief any time taxes
go down. It's the relief of a burden. So even
though the real situation with taxes is you need
well-balanced taxes and well allocated in order
to pay for the things that we all expect would
be paid for through taxation, tax relief less.
Listen, we're relieving people of this burden. So
sometimes the left is completely correct on the
position and they assume that the facts alone
will win people over. And the right's like,
No, we can just come up with a better slogan.
So two different categories, they're seniors.
Speaker 4: It makes perfect sense, I really agree
with what you're saying, I also think I liked
what you were saying the other day as well about
these kind of politicians who seem to kind of
be doing everything with the coronavirus like
wrong and incorrectly, they could kind
of be called let pro-vaccine. I think
things like that is like a really good idea
Speaker 1: to throw virus. You mean pro virus?
Speaker 4: Yeah, pre-virus. Sorry.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah. Yeah, no,
definitely. I mean, let's call them what they
are. They seem to be on the side of the virus
and especially when, OK, they might refuse
the vaccine, but you're also going to refuse
getting tested. Like, what's the reason?
That doesn't make any sense. So yeah,
these are all relevant examples.
Speaker 4:
OK, thank you so much for answering my questions.
Speaker 1: My pleasure, I appreciate the call.
All right, SHINee's from
Nottingham, UK. Great, great call.